بالكاد يوجد ما يكفي من الضوء
لرؤيتنا ونحن نتجه نحو خيمة سامية
وأحدها شفاه مخيمات مترامية الأطراف قبل بضع ليالٍ ،
انخفضت درجات الحرارة إلى ما دون الصفر
ولم يكن لدى الأسرة ما يكفي من
الحشد ولم أفقد أخبرهم الأطباء
أنه تجمد  حتى الموت يخرج زوجها
قبل أن ينهار ، ليس
لديها صورة تم تبنيها على قيد الحياة
فقط هذه الصورة حيث قالوا وداعهم الأخير
لا يمكنها أن تسامح نفسها ،
لا يمكنها أن تفهم كيف يمكن أن تكون الحياة رائعة للغاية.
لقد قمنا
برحلات متعددة إلى محافظة أدلب ، لم يكن أي منها
مثل هذه الطرق في جميع أنحاء
المحافظة مسدودًا بحركة مرور أولئك الذين
يركضون في موجات لا تنتهي ، وقد تم تهجير العديد منهم
عدة مرات من قبل ، ولكن هذه
المرة يختلف
شعورهم بغض النظر عما
فعلوه.  لنكون قادرين على تجاوز الحرب التي
سار فيها هؤلاء الأطفال لمدة سبع ساعات
في منتصف الليل للابتعاد
عن القصف بالقرب من قريتهم ،
لكنهم يريدون المغادرة من هنا ليس بعيدًا بما يكفي ،
لكنهم  إنهم بحاجة إلى محاولة
اكتشاف وسائل النقل والأشياء إذا
حاولوا السير على الأقدام ، فسيكون ذلك مستحيلًا
على الطريق ديما ويمسك باتولي
حيواناتهم المحنطة للمرة الأخيرة
لأن عالمهم لا تعتبر فيه الألعاب
ضرورية للبقاء على قيد الحياة.
يبكي أو يشتكي من أنه تم
تحميلهم في الشاحنة ،
فهناك شعور بالخوف من
الأماكن المغلقة يتفاقم بسبب
البؤس الجماعي لأولئك المحاصرين هنا
مع النظام الذي يغلق بسرعة
ويفرغ مناطق بأكملها استقرت قرية واحدة
بين أنقاض القرن الثالث هذه
لمدة أسبوعين  منذ ما مضى
، أظهر لنا طفل صغير صورة وهاتف والده الذي
تعرض للقصف خلال الليل ، هذا هاتف موهان
نيد وهو في العاشرة من عمره ، وقال إنه كان
خائفًا جدًا في الليلة الماضية لأن هذه
المنطقة بأكملها على سفوح التلال في كل مكان أو
تعرضوا للقصف ، كادوا ينطلقون
يمشون فيها  الظلام الذي اعتاد أن يكون
مدير المدرسة الابتدائية في القرى ،
تعتبر خيمته قصرًا وفقًا
لمعايير الوجود البائسة هذه ، فإن
أطفاله هم أصغر من اللازم.  لمعرفة أي شيء
سوى الحرب والمشقة ، هناك متشرد
في زيلر ، تعال حزينًا ،
هل لديك فرصة لأولئك الموجودين هنا يعرفون
جيدًا أنه من وجهة نظر العالم ، يمكن
الاستغناء عنهم في السنوات التسع الماضية ، علمتهم
أن طاعة الخيمة تطفو  على
قمة تل بعيدًا عن عدد لا يحصى من
المعسكرات المؤقتة الأخرى ، تم تفكيك محادثتنا من
خلال تحذيرات من OP لديه
على هاتفه
حول مكان تحليق الطائرات
وقصف والدته المسنة في
الزاوية التي كانت على هذا النحو منذ
أن اكتشفوا ذلك  توفي شقيقه في
سجن النظام والنظام
يقترب ، هذا شقيقه الذي
تم اعتقاله في عام 2012 عندما كان جزءًا
من الاحتجاجات
ثم في عام 2015 تلقوا إخطارًا
لماذا ابتعدت نوعًا ما عن القزم هذه
هي الصورة التي حصلوا عليها  منه ميتًا
في السجن ،
حسنًا ، يصبح
لا شيء في هذا المكان المهجور
مضمونًا ذهب ضحك ساحة المدرسة
والفصول الدراسية المزدحمة التي
تم تحويلها إلى ملاجئ
ودخان  قادنا أماكن المعيشة ولكن حتى مع
وصول عائلات جديدة ، فإن بعض هؤلاء هنا
يستعدون للفرار مرة أخرى
يقول فدين الذي التقينا به في المخيم
والأطلال ترسل لي رسالة صوتية مؤلمة
عندما وصلنا أصوات
العنف تضيق صدى عبر
التلال.  يلعب 15 طفلاً في
الوحل على ما يبدو غافلين عن
الخطر الذي يقترب أو اعتادوا للتو على
الخيال للاحتفال الذي طلبوه
لشاحنة ، لكنهم يتواجدون معهم ، لذا
فإن الطرق مزدحمة للغاية وتكتظ
بالناس الآخرين الذين يفرون من أولئك الذين
تمكنت من الحصول على وسائل النقل حزم أمتعتهم
ما زالوا يتشبثون بالأمل في
أن ينقذهم شيء ما
حتى يدرك العالم أنه لم يعد بإمكانه
الابتعاد عنهم لن يتم التخلي عنهم
ليبحثوا بشدة عن شريان حياة
غير موجود
أروى ديمون  سي إن إن هي محافظة في سوريا
أنت